partito ciao ragazzi e mezzanotte quindi
non posso urlare troppo mi sono
ritagliato questo momento per genere
questo guglielmo tell
l'europa deve chiedersi perché ti sei
ritirato solamente questo momento per
girare il guglielmo tell perché ho
passato tutto un giorno impegnato a
dover non far niente quindi sono adesso
mi sono reso conto sola ritardo che mi
deve dare una mossa quindi bando alle
ciance iniziamo subito richiesto su
instagram di farmi sapere che cosa
avrebbe devo fare in questi giorni a
casa da solo ne fossero stile domande
qualsiasi cosa ha messo areate raga un
bel po fatti mezzo che abbiamo sgravato
ho dovuto per forza fare una selezione e
adesso ho una serie di attività da fare
io non credo di riuscire a portare a
compimento alcune di queste stare su una
verticale per 10 secondi
troviamo poi sostare e verticale ma
attivo se va bene tre secondi mi sento
vietata ginnaste vite parallele come si
chiama perché la libreria capito in quel
dietro in un micron di testa e io non so
compare fino a 10 non so se come non so
se non so non so parlare questa aveva
tratte ludina che ora l'inter era nel
letto io
non sto riuscendo a facile appena quei
300 meeting stop
fatto dicci qualcosa in lingua elfica
bastava solo chiedere il nemico abbiamo
passato i nostri anni al liceo a
studiare in questo perché volevamo
parlare la lingua di legolas
mi ricordo solamente helen sì la lumen
menti euro se non sbaglio che voleva
dire una stella brilla sull'ora del
nostro incontro ma anche nuova fare
kiriaki incontrerà una nave bianca ti
vedrà una nave bianca in curva ricordo i
file in ecce ringa su mari assere mywi
ai miei posso costruire gli una cosa
oppure no pesca un libero d'occhi chiusi
dalla libreria apri la pagina 102 la
prima frase descriverà la tua vita
davvero bellissimo fa però anche
volevano sapere che cosa riesce
salgo su che è più di ok ho preso ho
preso oddio i miei amori di giacomo
casanova ho paura a 102 la prima frase
di senso compiuto è ma avrei ben voluto
portare con me anche il mio bel buco
oggetto di tante pene e speranze perdute
beh beh beh se esaustiva un autoritratto
sottosopra
nel senso che devo mettermi io sotto
sopra cioè col sangue la testa a
disegnarne o disegnarmi al contrario e
poi quando l'ho giro io sottosopra non
mi ci metto andrea veloce vediamo in
porto
ok perfetto 3 2 1 assomiglia a qualcuno
e conosco ma non sono io canto è già
pluri non posso contare questore a
questa faccio domani
amon 10 amon 10
amore
voglio un figlio da collo da comodi dal
coni
datemi fisico
d'argon di indire alle 17 proprio questa
l'ultima settimana appena ma non mi dico
la copy svuota tutte le mensole della
cucina per trovare l'origine delle
farfalline di me ragazzi in questo
martedì
l'ho trovata dovrei avere alcune cose
che ho girato che vi rimonto adesso
areate ragione ci avevate ragione c'era
un tipo delle larve borri b è un blog è
uscito due giorni fa quindi realtà
potete anche andarlo a vedere uno dei
wikus proprio dirvi che avevate ragione
cioè in uno scaffale c'erano tipo delle
merci arve una roba indegna ti prego te
lo chiedo da anni ci fai il tuo albero
genealogico così ci capiamo qualcosa
questa una delle domande mi fate sempre
e la cosa bella è che rispondo sempre ma
lo rifarò allora enrico gianmarco
creativi una grafica mio nonno e mia
nonna che insieme hanno avuto tre figlie
margherita piera silvana mari vita ha
avuto lavigne per francesco fiera ha
avuto giulia gianmarco beatrice e davide
mentre silvano ha avuto guglielmo
gabriele gianluigi ed enrico questa è la
parentela base poi in realtà ci sono
anche altri cugini sicuri che sono i
figli della cugina del cugino di primo
grado delle tre sorelle io che aveva
essere stato abbastanza chiaro la
challenge della verticale al muro di
carlotta ferlito perché perché oggi sono
verticali challenge verticale abbiamo
del cash sfilarsi la tuta in verticale
ma io non ce la faccio
ma questa è la pa in verticale mani sono
sconvolto ma siete pazzi
proverò a parla e non so perché ci avete
così tanto bisogno di avere il sangue al
cervello forse perché durante questa
quarantana tutto il sangue sta defluendo
altrove impara uno di quei balletti
scemi su tik tok ti prego allora
purtroppo non posso mettervi in musica
acqua altrimenti di youtube sinca ma io
ho un balletto che voglio fare da una
vita che questo è un giapponese con
carcerati di avere po po po po po po po
po po po po po è questo qui è il massimo
del balletto che potevo farli non è che
sia molto brava a ballare in generale mi
sento mortificato nell'animo inizia il
video con l'interessante delle potter in
testo senza farle cadere
non credo di avere un cranio come lo
permetta di così commentate qui ho la
testa più piatta dove se c'era la
fontanella sulla fronte basta basta
basta non ce l'ha adottata scaricati toh
che ricrea il primo video che vedi vedi
che il calciatore sei tu stai facendo
una figura e caciotta
[Applauso]
cioè oggi
impara a fare la sua carica ma veramente
che cosa una puntata delle olimpiadi ma
che diventa ma come faccio ma anche
volendo proviamo non potrò mai chiedere
le gambe
lasciatemi qui ma un briciolo di pietà
non ce l'abbiamo chiama enrico e dirgli
qualcosa di divertente un abbraccio
fatti di scrive al telefono un pokémon
uno sconosciuto e disegnano fra queste
due cose insieme sei sveglio e ricovero
questo ora è tardi risalto e 40 per cui
non dorme mai prima a chiamarlo enrico
si sveglio e allora devo chiedere una
cosa
innanzitutto è a tuo fratello maggiore
non glielo dici e lo tratti con rispetto
sappi che nel medioevo io sarei stato
retto sarei stato un servitore o un
prete non ha giustamente era in quel
caso gabriele sarebbe stato re e tu
sempre un prete contatto un secondo
no mi sono fatto una foto comunque i buy
iniziati scriver melo sei pronto
sì un occhio gip si vede caviglie con
dell'effetto nei camini
ma alle scarpe che con le scarpe aspetta
dove va detto non è pronunciato mi sono
reso conto che realtà delle ali
immaginavo che ci avesse praticamente
messe davanti tipo parannanza aspetta
che si sta bloccando qui ci provano
un'altra videocamera dicevamo è questa
lì è come se si formassero uno smoking
però aperto sui fianchi perché sono
delle ali ali egizie agli egizi impicca
cioè cosa connessione come pergine
disegnarlo bene da dove dovrebbe uscire
una camicia fuoriescono due occhi che
hanno la stessa forma dell'occhio suo ea
delle orecchie sopra dove niente ti
prende di me lasciano un po di spazio
nel petto e alla bologna una giacca però
una sorta di paranza ma che capito che
non è scelto a una decorazione sulla
scena della la vabbè ma la faccio di
testa mia se non finisce più questo
campo le piccione delle righe finito ok
finito allora questo qui è vedere
l'attimo mio risultato
sei pronto cioè allora fammi vedere
comunque non è si guidava le prato nella
giacca e poi perché gli atti piedi da
non è male non è terribile ho visto cose
peggiori tipo il tuo viso e tu mi hai
detto base amici si fanno mandorla un
occhio egizio [ __ ] egizio impara a
scrivere con l'altra mano il mancino lo
vedete non so perché ho iniziato in un
modo o in un altro aspettate mi riprendo
mentre lo faccio così però in
stampatello
ci può stare ci può dare un bello potrei
fare un tour della mia libreria ragazzi
c'è un video che uscito nel quale lo
faccio se volete vederlo cliccate qui e
qui spero che già mi mette il link non
pensavo veramente che una libreria in
questo caso lei potesse dire così tanto
di una persona mette una gamba del
tracollo
io e zone touch o 32 anni non le posso
fa ste cose ma ancora fronte le scotto
perdevo piede mario scotto carne non ce
la faccio parla cilena ciò senza porre
permesso un piacere arrivo subito allora
questi sono i grand nachos by el sabor
cilli flavour christian delicious from
nasce dalle corna
innanzitutto vorrei dirvi che nessuno
paga per dirvi questo ma tra sentiero
dovete comprarvi di quanto mi rialzo lo
riscatti vado ancora a guardare questo
video spegnetelo andate a comprare 5
farvi un becco e sapore impara giallo
dire di cannes al piano
domani
la lancia a capo già messa
ai
[Musica]
ok
cerca e legge una fan fiction su di turn
over esistono
siamo in periodo natalizio alcuni
parenti saranno a casa di guglielmo per
pranzo ci saranno due zie una loro
figlia mia nome josie però qualcosa di
più porno però nachos bayern sabor il
mio sogno presso il vostro sponsor
allora ragazzi insieme arrivate alla
fine di questo video ma mi sa anche il
genero domani quindi a tra poco
questo è il giorno dopo non sono
cambiate tante cose in realtà non so
nemmeno perché abbia passato la palla
almeno il futuro ma credo che quello che
volesse dire vogliamo è passato
siamo arrivati alla fine questo video i
granai rus bayern zaborra anche il
giorno dopo campi come se esce per 27 è
piaciuto questo video mettetevi un
pollice in su per il fatemi sapere quei
commenti che cosa vorreste vedere in
futuro se guglielmo tell soprattutto
iscrivetevi a questo canale attiva della
campanella fate tutte queste cose se
beva altrimenti istigativi mando un
bacio grandissimo ci vediamo domenica
con un cucina buttata ciao
[Musica]
vabbè stanno suonando gli allarmi cani
abbaiano
[Musica]
ciao